where's my magic when I'm in public use
my magic cuz people can't know I'm a
genie will Smith granting the wishes of
these four year old twins at the Aladdin
premiere back in may but get this it
turns out Mila and Emma Stouffer are
famous in their own right as part of
instagrams most followed family we're in
charge of our target so crazy yeah you
heard that right these four year olds
have a clothing line at Target all these
people are buying our clothes their
Instagram following is up to 3.9 million
and their YouTube videos have surpassed
85 million views mom Katie says she and
the girls make more money than her
husband and he's a doctor
the twins road to stardom started when
their older sister posted a video of
them on their mom's Instagram it went
viral the rest is history
even Reese Witherspoon is a fan but
sorry Reese it's a weird they don't know
who Kim K is either your mom oh we don't
know him yeah they went
trick-or-treating at Chris's house for
Halloween are you guys princesses and
they'd love to do a video with Justin
Bieber
here's what all the hype is about Justin
Bieber's in your bottle but despite
their stardom these little ladies don't
have Hollywood dreams for when they grow
up I want to be a doctor just like your
dad our dad is a god
[Music]